well we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar data data everywhere
using a complexity analysis to find her
hands and cancer big data and render
kelly kim of lab would smile be
moderating this session today's
educational web seminars presented by
lab leads the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
it's brought to you by roche diagnostics
as a global leader and how a large
diagnostics offers a broad portfolio of
tools that help healthcare providers in
the early detection prevention diagnosis
and treatment of diseases and molecular
diagnostics we are driven by a vision of
working of laboratories like yours to
improve the medical value you offer in
microbiology infectious diseases
oncology and genomics we continue to
meet unmet unit through our investment
in research innovation and scientific
excellence with the goal of supporting
your important role and improving
patients lives to learn more please
visit us diagnostics volcom this
presentation has been a free or
continuing education credits you want to
obtain credits for this presentation
please click on the get your free CME
credits button located in the lower left
of your screen this will take you to a
page listing all of our speakers and
presentations select the appropriate see
ECM button under your presentation and
follow the instructions to earn your
certificate let's get started you can
pose questions to our speaker during
this presentation while they're fresh in
your mind to do so simply type them into
the Q&A box which will open when you
click the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation Hinda questions
will be answered after the presentation
and we'll try to get to as many as we
can to enlarge the slide window click on
the screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you
experience any technical difficulties
hearing or seeing this presentation
properly please let us know by clicking
on the support button found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problems for the green Q&A
dalton
I would now like to present today's
speaker dr. Kenneth Bhutto dr. buetow is
a human genetics and genomics research
earthy leverages computational tools to
understand complex traits because cancer
liver disease and obesity dr. buetow
currently serves as director of
computational sciences and informatics
program of complex adaptive systems at
Arizona State University and is a
professor in the school of life sciences
in ASU's College of Liberal Arts and
Sciences more information on dr. details
background click on his name to see his
experience I'll now turn it over to Ken
for his presentation thank you very much
and I want to thank the audience for
their joining in I realize I'm betting
somewhat clean up from the day's events
what I hope to do is in in the time
allotted to me today actually is
introduce you all to the emerging
concepts of big large-scale data
associated with the in the cancer
community and hopefully give you some
interesting new ideas as to how we might
go about embracing this big day to help
us solve some of the complex problems
associated with cancer so as this
community I think is more than aware
we're in an unprecedented window in
which we're collecting phenomenal
amounts of data shown on the current
slide is is it actually an old figure
from 2012 that suggested that we would
have tens of thousands of copies of the
human genome that actually help us
better understand complex diseases such
as cancer much of the sequencing is
being driven by cancer what we see is in
fact that we have well over shot those
numbers when we look at the actual
number sequences is the end of last year
almost 300,000 human genomes have been
sequences much much in the cancer
community as a way to help us both
understand the underlying etiology of
cancer but
so to help us drive a next generation of
Diagnostics that said what we're seeing
is a very large collection of raw data
and to leverage a story of a quick
metaphoric story of a young girl who
wanted wanted wanted to have a pony when
she came out on the day of her birthday
saw a large pile of manure in the on her
driveway and then immediately jumped in
and her parents to that end said why did
you jump in and they said there must be
a pony in there somewhere and arguably
our large-scale accumulation of this
data promises that there must be a cure
for cancer in there somewhere this
promissory note is actually being driven
by the large-scale personalized and/or
precision medicine revolution and again
as this audience knows personalized or
precision medicine is about delivering
to the right individual the right care
at the right time and in the right place
tailoring their therapeutic
interventions to the molecular etiology
of their disease this clearly is both
revolution in the sense of our capacity
to uniquely tailor our interventions to
the characteristics of their two of an
individual's disease but arguably it's
also Renaissance and renaissance in the
form that much the same as the old
country doctor used to know all of the
unique characteristics of the patient
not only their disease but also their
their personal preferences their
cultural background and could tailor
their interventions around this and in
fact the new emerging big data in cancer
is helping us both have revolution and
Renaissance but let's focus on the
molecular piece of this for a second but
precision medicine revolution that is
before us that it shown here is it is a
cover of Time literally with the poster
child would personalize not
levack suggesting that we actually were
at a tipping point in our understanding
and our ability to treat cancer and
while unequivocally there these new
precision medicine guided therapeutics
have been tremendous successes it's also
important to recognize that they have
their limitations and shown on this
slide is another current survival chart
showing what actually happens with these
targeted interventions or is a synonym
and what we can see is that
unequivocally there is an effect and an
important effect associated with his
disease and with this newer intervention
but what we can also see in this
instance is that the mean change in
survival here is that of 20 weeks so
while there is a miraculous
transformation of this individuals of
individuals disease when treated with
these targeted therapeutics what we can
see is that the large scale that the
effects are actually quite minimum and
actually measured in in weeks as opposed
to years and certainly not a cure and I
guess more disheartening is that even
though with great promise of these
personalized treatments we still see
that the survival curves here still
unfortunately even with these mean
improvements are not necessarily
providing us the cures for cancer and
I'll come back to that in a second
before the end of the talk is to what
well transitioning to now as to why that
may be the case and show you that
hopefully by taking slightly different
strategies we make it to a better
outcome so why is it the case that we
continue to get these why is it that
even with our precision medicine
targeting that we're not actually
getting the cure is to cancer that we
hope and I guess I wanted to go with the
fact that to be honest with you cancer
it's complicated so while we have the
promissory note that if
could find a key mutation and cancer and
target that specific cancer what we're
finding what we find is that cancer is
more complicated than this specific
single individual mutation we might be
targeting so what do I mean by that well
first as this group I'm sure is aware
cancer we now know from two or three now
solid decades of molecular biologic
investigation is a disease that occurs
with the change in the genomic
constitution of a collection of cells
that goes from a normal state to a
malignant state but what's important in
this is that what we see here is that
this is not a mutation that occurs but
actually dozens and in this instance
when I would indicate is while my
cartoon only shows two or three that
molecular data indicates that there are
literally dozens to hundreds of
mutations that are occurring more
disturbingly as dozens to hundreds of
mutations actually of are different
between any two individuals so for
instance one woman with breast cancer
may have a hundred different mutations
that have occurred another woman with
breast cancer will have a hundred but
the overlap between these is small so
there's a large collection of diverse
things happening the other thing that we
see that emerges is that these cells are
actually also differentiating so it's
not that there's one uniform clone of
cancer cells emerging but in fact cancer
sis cancer is creating a whole new organ
or actually more accurately organism
within one that actually has dynamic
properties that change over time I'll
come back to that in a second we also
know that these mutations can occur in a
variety of different ways so obviously
we can have DNA based mutations where we
have single point mutations but
mutations can also occur by changing
large-scale copies of the total number
of variants that one would have big
chunks of DNA chain
we can have changes in the gene
expression so again no necessary change
in the underlying nucleic acids
associated with a gene we just make more
of the genes we can see that there are
non nucleic acid-based means by which
this happens epigenetic modifications we
now know that outside of the gene based
genome that in fact there's all sorts of
alterations happening in what we used to
describe is the ninety-five percent of
the human genome that was junk and in
fact important phenomena occur as a
product of those components and lastly
there's all sorts of things that aren't
even in the nucleic acid or proteomic
space that are being modified to cause
or to accumulate in the developing
cancer so not a single mutation that has
occurred or a antigen but dozens of
changes occurring through many different
molecular mechanisms we also know that
these particular collections of
mutations actually have to alter
specific processes and what we can see
on this slide is that there's you know
six different processes being shown and
in fact depending on how you want to
categorize them there's five six seven
eight different kinds of processes the
cancer needs to change in order to
develop in this instance though while we
put a single label for safer instance
stealing their maintenance or evade
apoptosis what we realize is that there
are complex biomimetic biomolecular
networks that actually are responsible
for these particular processes if they
uh proptosis isn't one gene or one
phenomena but it's a whole network of
interconnected genes and signaling
frameworks necessary in order to
actually have that process work
similarly for tomato maintenance and
cell cycle regulation and what we can
see is when we look at those hundreds of
alterations some of them dna-based
mutations some of them are other forms
of alterations we can see that an
individual one we may target one
particular member of the
work in individual two will charge will
target a different member of the network
in individual three a different member
of the network so while the network is
being disrupted it's not being disrupted
in the same way in all different in
different people we also know that that
what's happening at the somatic level is
only one to mention cancers occur within
hosts hosts themselves have millions of
genetic variations in them so for
instance the DNA I inherited from my mom
is different in a million different
locations from the DNA I inherited from
my dad those different constitutional
differences influence basic cellular
processes ranging anywhere from
angiogenesis to the basic cellular
matrix to how my immune system can
respond and also influence how my body
and my on how the host sees the external
world and modify things such as chemical
exposures viruses nutrition and how
those all are influencing the
development of cancer so so suffice it
to say that while we precision medicine
may be targeting a entity cancer is
complicated or perhaps more
appropriately it's very complicated so
we ignore this complexity at our peril
and I think this has been well stated by
a paper last year in cancer cell by
Robert Weinberg an initial proponent
that if we could just find the oncogene
or tumor suppressor gene that cure for
cancer was before us and that precision
medicine would be an unfair you know an
unequivocal success Weinberg bees come
to the point of recognizing that we
those simple answers just aren't
producing the results that we would hope
and then in fact it's essential that we
go back to embracing the full complexity
of cancer so cancer is not only
complicated as I've just shown in a
series of slide it's complex so again
reiterating and summarizing the previous
point it's hundreds of alterations that
there
from individual to individual those very
those tumors are molecular molecular ly
heterogeneous within an individual and
that heterogeneity changes over time in
response to a variety of different
variety different stimuli so as we can
see again at the bottom of this figure
of this slide we can see how the
molecular constitution changes over time
and the mutational composition of a
tumor is different at time a versus time
B versus time see each one of these has
a different molecular constitution by
saying complex I'm actually using this
not in the general sense of the word but
actually in the precise sense of the
word cancer is a complex adaptive system
or complex system and the significance
of this is that means that cancer and
the underlying etiology of cancer isn't
determined by single isolated effects
but as with all complex systems driven
by relationships interconnectedness of
particular events that change over time
as is implicit from what we said before
cancer actually learns and adapts out in
response to particular conditions and
importantly because it's based on these
relationships it can't be fully
understood by taking apart the pieces
and then reassembling them in an
arithmetic way it displays emergence in
this instance the whole being more than
the sum of the part these relationships
specify something that's more than one
plus one in cancer one plus one equals
three now why is that important well
it's important because unlike
traditional approaches to fixing things
you can't fix a complex system because
of the complexity of the interacting
parts what one needs to do is instead
alter the trajectory of the system and
I'll come back in closing
where we're standing and where we're
going with what appear to be newly
emerging approaches to cancer that are
quite accept that are quite successful
over and above the precision medicine
point of view those therapies appear to
be embracing this concept of altering
trajectory rather than just fixing or
eliminating the broken pieces so if what
we what we really want to be doing from
all of this large collection of data
that large pile of data that I mentioned
before is translating that data into
information to do that we need to
understand relationships between the
datum of the cells and more importantly
what we want is knowledge or evidence
and that allows us to not only
understand those relationships but one
of the patterns of those relationships
and how do they change over time so what
I'm going to spend the rest of my talk
talking about is how we're approaching
the problems of understanding
relationships and understanding patterns
and applying those to the cancer problem
so let's stop first with discovering and
understanding relationships so part of
what we've been doing is embracing the
inherent network structure of cancer
specifically in the somatic variation of
cancer to start with but also in the
germline variation those two different
components I showed a moment ago so our
approach to understanding somatic
variation leverages analytic approaches
developed by my colleague previous post
dr. saleh phony who is now at bar-ilan
university and in this instance what we
use is biologic networks or biologic
pathways as our unit of analysis we look
not at individual genes but actually
combine the information from individual
genes and look at how they are
interacting literally looking at the
places where one plus one equals three
to try to better understand what's
emerging and what's developing in cancer
in particular what we do is take an
embrace this complexity by computing
pathways scores looking at existing
canonical biological networks that we
can achieve that we recover from the
literature and then using in this
instance that experiments i'm going to
show right now using RNA seek data
that's been normalized by standard tools
look and calculate how this state the
presence or absence the up or down of
genes influences our works in the
combination of network frameworks the
specific focus i'm going to describe
here is how we were using our using RNA
seek the transcriptional response to
evaluate a therapeutic intervention
that's being explored by colleagues from
Tata Memorial Hospital looking at
progesterone treatment in cancer so in
this instance as i mentioned we're
looking in partnership with dr. broadway
and his colleagues at tata memorial
hospital in mumbai india as shown on the
on the left-hand side of your slide is a
sample set that we're looking at but
again in an attempt to embrace the
complexity what we're going to analyze
here is not just the individual genes
but we're going to look at how those
individual genes change in the context
of networks between those in response to
the treatment but the other thing that
dr. Broadway quite insightful e has done
here is not only collect the cancer
samples to see what has actually
happened in them but also collected
tumor adjacent so we can see what's
happening not just in the cancer but
also see what's happening in normal or
uninvolved tumor associated with the
cancer and he's also done something
that's very unusual but I think it's
interesting and important that may be
critical for us better understanding the
molecular etiology of cancer he's looked
at what the actual effect of the
surgical intervention is and I'll come
back to that in a second so so we can
not only look to see how the
intervention is changing the genic
profile but we can also see how it
actually changes the normal profile in
individuals and how even the baseline
intervention the surgical process by
which we the tumors are being treated
also changes things so i'll start with
the sort of basic intervention and what
I'm showing here is the outputs the
results of this pet of this preliminary
pathway analysis that's associated with
surgical hypoxia as this audience as I'm
sure is aware the first step one does
when one does surgical interventions is
to clamp off the blood supply to the
tissue that in which this tumor is being
extracted what we found here is
interestingly and importantly is
independent of any therapeutic
intervention independent of whether
you're looking at tumor or normal in
this instance the very act of just
clamping the blood supply to the tumor
actually changes its molecular profile
and in this instance we can see that
several of the critically important
genes that are excuse me of molecular
networks that are have been associated
with orogenesis are appear to be acutely
sensitive dramatically change their
state just as the act of hypoxia so
again this may be important and helping
us target and generate future
interventions to realize that the state
that we are treating is immediately
change the state of the disease that
we're that we're treating is immediately
changed just by doing the surgical
intervention not any other of not any
other sort of molecular or targeted
intervention so shown here is just some
blow ups of this and more cartoonish
forms I realize it's probably difficult
to read the specific pathways but to be
honest we think those are captured on
the other tables this is just
graphically showing how the states of
the network change is a product of the
hypoxia you can see blue me
they have been turned off red being that
they've been turned on and you can see
relatively dramatic differences that are
occurring at the summary state level of
the pathways we can also see that
interestingly the point of these next
two slides is to show that the answers
we get are different when we look at the
pathway interactions as opposed to the
specific gene so here you can see what
happens if we look at hypoxic and non
hypoxic samples individual genes that we
can see individual gains some small
number of individual genes that change
but to be honest the pattern is not
radically different in the hypoxic
versus the non hypoxic however if we
then look at the gene interactions what
we can see is that there are many more
and profound differences that are
occurring in the hypoxic samples versus
the non hypoxic so we can see radical
changes that are occurring that have
profound effects on the on the scoring
of the differences between hypoxic of
non hypoxic we can do a similar sort of
analysis with respect to the non tumor
tissue again traditionally not done in
these and but what we can see is
dramatic network changes that occur as a
product of the actual int of the that's
independent of whether your cancer or
not so these are just baseline changes
in normal cells and knowing that these
baseline state changes occur may be
important than helping us understand how
to actually minimize toxicity or to
increase effectiveness so we've now
actually seen the whole dimensions of
the cancer that don't normally that
aren't normally being evaluated when we
look at just simple changes that occur
in the tumor pre and post-treatment so
here is again the same effect in the
tumors and that what's interesting to
see and difficult from this summary
slide here where the pathway names are
small is that these pathways that we're
seeing actually are different of
the different combinations so shown here
is then a summary in a slightly more
readable form that we show the specific
pathways that are different within the
pre and post normal treatment pre and
post tumor so again the accumulation of
these actually gives us insight that we
have before in this instance insight as
to how that act of doing surgery is
changing the molecular state of the
tumors and how actually the intervention
itself changes not only the tumor or
prizes molecular changes not only in the
tumor but also how it's producing
changes in the normal and we believe the
triangulation of this information will
allow us to develop new much more
effective interventions and then shown
here I'm sorry this is just one more
cartoon when we look at the differences
between non-tumor and tumor without
treatment with treatment and similarly
summary effects so I now would actually
shift my gears to actually looking not
at the somatic tumor itself but looking
at the constitutional state so as you
recall in my opening comments I
indicated that we not only had two that
weren't only an importance of effects
occurring within the tumor itself but
the host itself has the individual in
which cancer occurs also has important
characteristics that are that may change
how who develops cancer and how they
would respond so in this analysis we're
using a methodology is developed by
another one of my colleagues former
students a rosemary Braun a process
process that looks at germline variation
using pathways of distinction analysis
and basically what this methodology does
is allows us to look at how the
molecular characteristics that
constitutional variable state of an
individual is different in individuals
who have cancer versus individuals who
haven't who don't have cancer our focus
on this has been actually in looking at
an unusual in a
a new collection of risk factors to
developing cancer that of diabesity so
let me spend a minute or two talking
about this many of you are probably
familiar with the exploding obesity
epidemic that's occurring in the
developed world shown here is a slide
that indicates that what that looks like
I think what most people are surprised
by when they see this slide is not that
we see high rates of diabetes or obesity
in the United States or that we see such
trends in Europe or in the developed
world what strikes most people in this
is that we see these also in the
developing world India and China and
that granted both India and China have
big numbers because they have big
populations what you'll also see in this
is that and the underlying date of this
indicates that they're developing middle
class and their affluent class the folks
that actually are being exposed to
Western diet seem to be particularly
susceptible to diabetes City and
diabetes as this group is probably aware
obesity causes many different types of
phenotypes what we're going to focus on
in our analysis here is how my cancer be
developing and can we actually predict
who is going to be developing cancer and
what are the processes driving the
development of cancer recently the role
between body mass index and obesity and
cancer has been reaffirmed by a recent
study in Lancet in this instance we see
that there on number of tumor types that
are increased in incidents among obese
individuals what I'm going to focus my
attention on in this talk in looking at
genetic analysis one particular type of
cancer that being liver cancer you might
ask why well the major reason I'm
focusing on liver cancer has to do with
concern that a pata cellular carcinoma
HCC
become to this generation what lung
cancer was to a previous generation of
individuals that with the advent of
obesity that we may have an epidemic of
liver cancer similar to with the advent
of smoking that occurred at the turn of
the 20th century post-world War 1 in
World War two and the explosion of lung
cancer are we likely to see a similar
sort of phenomenon emerging for liver
cancer so why might I be saying that
well first unlike many other cancers the
vast majority of other cancers are
either stable in incidents per 100,000
or decreasing hepatocellular carcinoma
or liver cancer is one of them to
cancers that has shown dramatic
increases in incidents over time shown
here is it work done by my colleague
Kathryn Atlanta the National Cancer
Institute looking at seer data of what's
been observed is over the last 30 years
there's literally been a doubling in all
racial groups of liver cancer incidents
one of the only other cancer showing
dramatic increases is pancreatic cancer
again another obesity and diabetes
associated cancer type what's big also
fascinating and transformational that
occurred over the last three decades is
we've seen a shift in the etiology of
liver cancer HCC from its original
driving forces hepatitis C virus
hepatitis V buyers and alcohol or
excessive alcohol consumption which
still have tremendously high odds ratios
tremendous relative risks associated
with their incidents but what's happened
in this theory decade period is we've
seen now that the primary etiology of
liver cancer is coming from obesity and
diabetes in this instance that now the
attributable risk or the attributable
fraction of liver cancer
is no longer due to virus or alcohol
exposure but due to obesity a tremendous
shift in the change of the etiology so
we could be seeing a raising epidemic
and part of our interest is trying to
figure out who is going to develop liver
cancer among those in these exposed
populations the reason that obesity may
be driving liver cancer is actually
perhaps surprisingly straightforward the
liver is one of the primary places that
in early places that fat is deposited
it's actually preferential location of
that deposition it actually makes in
terms of evolutionary adaptation makes
complete sense the liver is the primary
site of fat metabolism so and where the
process is the biochemical process is
necessary for pack for fat metabolism
occurred so not surprisingly one would
want to have it handy what's interesting
is that using evolutionary medicine
thinking is that over the adaptation
period of humans there's very little
selective pressure to figure out how to
stop deposition of that liver so in fact
fat in the liver doesn't has very poor
control mechanism so even when one is
obese the feedback loops that stop the
deposition of fat in the liver are
relatively poorly developed so so we
kelia logically understand why we are
depositing fatty liver we still don't
though don't understand why certain
people belong to develop liver disease
and others don't and that's the purpose
of our analytics so in this instance
we've been doing germline variation
analyses of study populations from Korea
and China looking at German wide jerma
genome-wide germline variation of very
high density and in these analyses what
we're seeing is that we're finding again
similar to what we saw
with our somatic cell analysis is by
analyzing networks we're getting very
strong signals that have a fifty percent
or more increase in developing liver
cancer looking at individuals who have
with our cancer versus individuals who
don't we can we see pathways that have
substantial contributions to
distinguishing those to whether the
pathway state is very different in those
two different sets of populations unlike
what we would find with individual snips
we actually have very large odds ratios
that are larger than one that even the
most significant individual snips for
single nucleotide polymorphisms so here
is just the score of one of these that's
important antigen processing and
presentation this is actually associated
with the immune response antigen
presentation and processing is the means
by which an individual's body recognizes
self and responds and regulate the
immune attack of one's own cells and or
cancer so it's interesting that one of
the critical responses to fatty liver
disease is an inflammation response so
it actually makes an interesting place
to follow up that perhaps individuals
who are developing liver cancer have a
different way that their immune system
is responding to this fatty liver onset
so the next piece I wanted to focus on
is not just under oath discovering and
understanding the networks or the
relationships but how do we go about
understanding the patterns and for this
I'm going to focus on the emerging
developing framework of successful
cancer interventions in immuno oncology
and if you know oncology I would argue
is a paradigm shifting approach and
you'll see why as a student of
complexity and complex adaptive systems
why I'm saying
this first off wire why is it mean
oncology and exciting new Advent and
complimenting and extending what perhaps
the precision medicine revolution will
do first is that it has durable
responses unlike what I showed with the
targeted therapeutics that are part of
the precision medicine framework we
actually one gets durable responses
associated with the application of
immuno oncology individuals actually for
all intents and purposes have responses
that are measured in years and for all
and perhaps are actually cured the other
interesting component is it's not tied
to a single mutation or a single cancer
type that is in fact applicable multiple
cancer types so why might that be the
case well one is an argument is that
Indian oncology is a conceptually
different approach what do I mean by
that well in traditional oncological
advances from the very GetGo that from
surgery on through our targeted
interventions that are part of the
precision medicine portfolio our
approach has actually been direct action
against the tumor surgically we remove
it chemotherapy we kill it and in the
target precision medicine our goals are
to return its growth well you know
oncology actually approaches the problem
differently and in this instance as i
said before how we intervene in complex
systems it actually alters the
trajectory of a complex system and it
does this through the manipulation of
the immune network so mu immuno oncology
and the immune system is itself a
network as this audience is aware the
immune system is a complex network of
interacting components and the immune
system is itself also a quintessential
complex adapting system that is entered
kit that is interconnected
self-regulating and
has a dynamic interaction with the tumor
itself so what we've been interested in
doing in embracing this complex adaptive
systems approach is developing
computational models of how the immune
system works and how it might then
interface with the children we're doing
this through models and simulations our
models and simulations are capturing
components that we know about the immune
system and about oncology from the
literature and from specific
reductionist experiments and then we're
looking through the analysis of this
large collection of data similar to what
i just showed in the previous analysis
to embrace the derived relationships
that we can get from approaching these
large collections of data and then what
we do is join these at interfaces to
both solve specific equation sets and to
simulate to get observed emergent
properties those one plus one equal
three class outcomes in this instance
we're embracing the community by bracing
the complexity by embracing both cancer
and the immune response as a system
looking at them both together and
understanding their dynamic relationship
using computational modeling it's a
combination of bottom-up and top-down
strategies that extends other modeling
approaches so I know it sounds always a
little radical when we say we going to
make computational models but models are
actually computational models would be
just yet one more tool in our
armamentarium almost everything we know
about cancer and almost any other
complex trait comes from our modeling
approaches and in this instance what we
want to be able to do is use
computational modeling to realistically
capture the same way we would do in a
genetically engineered mouse or in a
cell line specific characteristics and
see how those might work our specific
computational modeling captions in
agent-based simulation
components interacting cells immune
cells tumor cells cytokines receptors
and the environment in which these cells
occur we start with States based on what
we can observe in the literature we use
mathematical models of cell migrations
and cytokine diffusion and cell surface
receptor movements and then the idea is
by using and examining how these are
work we can see emergent properties so
our strategy is to model the micro
components of molecules and solutions
specifically sceptre elements on cell
types different types of cell types and
how immune cells come together and then
looking at dynamic behavior molecular
diffusion or molecule diffusion both in
solution how receptors move on
particular cell types how cells move in
solution or how they interact with each
other in matrix for instance in a tumor
set and then look for the specific
biologic actions and reactions about
biologic and phenotypic so we're looking
for emergent macro behavior from the
cell behaviour with given multiple
receptors how we get group action how we
get intra cellular networks change in
state and how the cell states themselves
change and how to get differences in the
immune cell population equilibrium how
do we get different characteristics and
how do we actually see how the immune
system may be acting to eliminate
balance or how tumors may be
manipulating the tumor may be
manipulating the immune system so that
they actually escaped detection so our
simulation framework is actually looking
essentially it's a large-scale low game
in which we actually simulate tumors and
immune components all working and
interacting with each other with
different dynamics just the same as the
characters would in a large
video game where we actually look and
measure units over time we capture the
logic of systems which can bind to each
other and can look at combinations of
multiple receptor types ligands and
different cell types we calculate the
dynamics using partial differential
equations shown in this slide so that we
actually do both top-down and bottom-up
agent Marlin but when we find and this
is probably a closing point that i'd
like to make around the context of big
data so while i opened the talk with
discussions of the overwhelming volume
of data that we're getting in genomic
sequence what we actually find is as we
want to actually start to embrace the
complexity of cancer it start to embrace
its multi-dimensional nature we realize
that in fact we are missing a lot of key
pieces of data so having big data in and
of itself is not necessarily to Seoul
answer to the question we need to have
the right kinds of data so if we want to
be actually embracing the complexity of
cancer we need to start having data not
only on the specific components of the
system we need to have been collected in
concert with each other we need to know
the immune profile of an individual we
need to know the molecular state of
multiple components not just individual
molecules we need a bday to be able to
be interconnected and probably the most
important piece that is missing from
much of our molecular characterizations
that we have accessible to us today is
the need for having temporal later we
very have very limited data that allows
us to actually look at how these
processes change over time and as I get
open with cancer is a complex system we
can see that cancer that we see today is
not the cancer that we may have had
yesterday and may not be the cancer that
we would
tomorrow both in terms of the molecular
constitution of the cells and if we're
interested in immuno oncology how is the
body responding to these specific
interventions and how is the cancer
itself changing and changing the host in
response so I'm going to close and
actually clearly hit a type of on this
is that reductionist approaches to
cancer are insufficient to obtain a full
understanding of cancer for us to
actually truly move and how successful
precision medicine that we all hope for
we need to have ways of looking at
cancer as a system not simply in the
reductionist components they are
insufficient to understanding the role
the full portfolio cancer we need to
actually see the components and how they
are working together network analysis
appears to bring coherence too chaotic
individual levels of data and through
that through the examination of these
networks we seem to be able to get
answers that we couldn't get at the
individual levels we actually think
dynamic modeling through simulation may
provide insights into complex emergent
phenomena we actually are quite
optimistic that by creating a
next-generation set of computational
models will be able to enhance what
we're doing with our current collection
of wet lab molecular cell line or other
animal based models but one of the
critical challenges that's going to be
facing the community as we go forward is
not just collecting big data and not to
say that big data have a data analyst
and we can and will find interesting
ponies in the piles that we're examining
but if we truly want to make progress in
personalized medicine and precision
medicine we may need to also embrace not
just collecting more of the same but
making sure we're collecting the right
kinds of
data to be able to ask and answer
questions so with that I want to
acknowledge all the folks that have
participated in this activity say thank
you and actually would volunteer anyone
I'm looking forward to getting questions
from the audience and anyone who's
interested in collaborating
participating contributing or making
suggestions as to how we might move
forward and please feel free to contact
me because we're always looking for
partners in this arena so with that I'll
turn that microphone back to our
moderator and look forward to
interacting with you all in answering
questions that you might have so thank
you very much for your thank you very
much thank you dr. buetow for bringing
that information to us for a great
presentation I'll just remind our
audience really quickly how they can
submit their questions type them in the
Q&A box found by clicking on the green
Q&A button at the lower left of the
presentation window and we Anna one
already dr. Bhutto an audience member
asks what rule do you think live cell
imaging has in looking at cancer as a
system so i actually think live cell
imaging and imaging overall is is going
to be the one of the next big explosions
in big data and in the phenotyping that
we have one of one of the challenges
that we have today in the molecular
frameworks that we're using is that they
actually don't actually let us see
what's happening to the cells per se I
think that the ability to be able to
image and visualize the specific cancer
phenotype is going to be
transformational it's yet another big
data problem with all sorts of
interesting opportunities and challenges
to extract the signals out of that big
data but we're confident that actually
having that is going to allow us to
pivot back and forth between what's
happening at the molecular level with
particular cancers or particular cell
types and their interactions and see
what's physically happening at the
cellular level
great sounds like that's very interest
rate another audience member has
question of your contact information
somebody wants know how to contact you
sure so you can reach sure so you can
reach me at Kenneth Yuto Kenneth bhutto
ke + n ETH gue teow at asu.edu happy to
actually interact with folks if there's
a interesting further Apollo of
questions or ideas as to how we might be
able to collaborate in approaching many
of these individual problems so I look
forward to the opportunity to connect
and interact with you all thank you for
providing that thanks so much for
providing that information for our
audience member we do have another
question coming into our cue let me see
here are there any software that you
suggest to process time series data so
there's a actually large portfolio date
of time series software that cap that's
captured actually in my personal
preference for many of these different
types of software has is to use the open
source community software because it
allows us to actually exchanged it
straightforwardly there are our modules
and python modules that are readily
available i'm happy to i won't be able
to rattle them off at the top of my head
that there's a number of components
certainly not to take anything away from
my commercial colleagues you know folk
success also have tools that facilitate
the analysis of time series data our our
conceptual approaches for these are to
look at mixed model analysis we actually
think that both linear and nonlinear
mixed model that
us to look at the both combinations of
random effects and fixed effects are
particularly powerful ways to approach
these we're working with colleagues that
are adding to that bayesian statistical
approaches that facilitate us having a
conditional estimation of individual or
facts so a lot of tools available
awesome we have another question what
about the current growth in metabolomic
data collection what kinds of metadata
do you think will be required to
maximally utilize it so I think
metabolomic and obviously the other
place that I spent almost no time
talking about that are interesting in
this context of microbiome X but
metabolomic sigh think looking
especially for disease like liver cancer
or liver disease are going to be
critically important because what's
happening with with these cells is
actually quite commonly captured in
what's happening in their dynamic
processes so I would actually argue that
the tableau Alex as it starts mature and
it has to be able to be communicated is
going to be an important dimension to
our complex systems what we're missing
in metabolomic says we're missing and
actually sadly much of biomedicine is a
is a lingua franca for the community to
communicate with each other so we're
there are emerging sets of standards
that would allow us to describe both the
experiments and the way that we've
captured data but I think minimally
because the taffa minute metabolomic siz
so much more dynamic than the genomic
space it's really critical that we know
they both the experimental conditions as
well as the specific characteristics of
the samples their preparation
other components in order to be sure
that when we actually get a result from
on the tab olymic evaluation that it's
not a product of the that's not product
of the experimental processing that it's
a product of the sample that went in so
does it be a few of the metadata okay
our next question is there a difference
in complexity between hereditary cancer
and sporadic cancer so I think that's an
excellent question and actually one that
ironically has been somewhat under
explored there's been a speculation that
in fact that hereditary cancer should be
simpler to study and in particular since
we do know that there is at least when
we look within families there should be
a common underlying mutational framework
that we could look at so in some sense
it is computationally simpler that said
as I started in the original
presentation though cancer unfortunately
is not due to a single gene so much of
the other complex units allowed cancer
they're necessary there's other biologic
processes even though you may still have
one or more of the phenomena you still
have a great deal of complexity but but
actually as a card-carrying geneticist
actually I think one of the things we
may need and would find value and is
going back to Family Studies and in
particular hereditary cancers because I
think we may be able to reduce some of
the complexity much of complexity
analysis is all about control
measurement of variability in hereditary
cancers we actually would know at least
one piece of the puzzle it's a little
bit like in solving a true puzzle one of
the things that's valuable to do is find
a corner piece or a side piece and by
having sunny hereditary cancer we would
have one of those
corner or side pieces to help us build
from super we have a follow-up question
from the audience member who was asking
about processing time series data are
you open to collaboration on these data
sets so very much so actually I I
neglected I almost always actually end
my talk with rather than having the
analogy side-slit put up a slide that
actually has both interested in
collaborating and then having my
personal information available for folks
to to reach out to me so yeah absolutely
we are always interested in finding
folks that have and have the potential
to add unique insights to the data sets
and more than happy to have a discussion
about how we might go about working
together in asking and answering
important questions against these data
sets great sure you'll get some interest
we do have another question what tool
that you use in the pathway analysis how
did you achieve p-value which statistics
so we used actually for the two sets of
pathway analysis that I showed we use
two different sets of tools the first
tool set and I'll pick I'll put you back
to the to the references I put in if you
wanted to get more details because it's
sort of imperfect to do this in this
form was a tool called pathologist it
was the core tenets of it were developed
by my by my colleagues so life for me
and the statistics associated with to
talk about are worked out in a package
the actual analytic packages were
developed a buyer by a Sharon Greenbaum
who actually also worked for us when I
was at the National Cancer Institute the
second package we use is pota a pathway
of distinction analysis it was the
by Louise Mary wrong so the the
pathologist analysis actually uses
standard statistical methods when we
actually compute the pathway scores to
evaluate the differences between those
particular magnitudes of the score so
tests not unlike a not unlike t-tests
looking at quantitative variables that
have pseudo random variation for the
path for the potent alice's because
we're looking at very non random data
and or non normal looking data we
actually again use a nonparametric
statistics in order to be able to
evaluate these but actually the key
distributions and p-values of
significance for the moda analysis are
driven by computational reefs and so we
actually permute the data resources to
generate a normal distribution and then
use those know the empiric null
distributions in order to evaluate
significance wait we have another
question from our audience does
cholesterol have anything to do with
breast cancer or is it only obesity so
that's a very interesting question
apologize in advance to say I don't know
enough of the interaction of the
relationship between cholesterol and
breast cancer it's been speculated
because regret cholesterol is the
precursor molecule for many types of
both hormones it's a precursor for many
of the immune components that it
certainly could be important but I
personally don't know that literature
well enough to actually give a crisp
answer to that somewhere apologies
okay I think we have time one more
question number one what examples of
multi all mixed integration yielding
insights into HCC can you point to so I
think that that's a an important
interesting question so so to date
there's been actually very little
integration of what we've seen in multi
omics in liver cancer or to be honest
with you in most cancers most on the
analytics that have been approached to
date have been isolated in the either
looking at nucleic acid somatic
variation germline variation
transcriptome levels of variation and
then in each of these they actually seem
to be studied in a single dimension what
I can tell you right now is at least in
liver cancer i'm not familiar with a
multi omics integration other than the
ones that we are literally doing that
are happening in my lab as we speak and
i guess what i might encourage you to do
is tune in to this come back to this
channel this station next year at this
time and hopefully i can actually share
with you some interesting insights that
we get by looking at multi-dimensional
data analysis and other cancer awesome
thank you can i'm sure i'll be back
that's all the time we have I'd like to
thank dr. ken detail for joining us
today and also to roche molecular
diagnostics for underwriting today's
educational webcast making it possible
to be here with you this webcast will be
on devant man through march of 2016 and
light leaks will be sending you an email
alerting you when this webcast is
available for replay we invite you to
share that email with your colleagues in
case they miss today's live event you
can tune in on demand that's all we have
for now until next time goodbye